we're asked to find the square root of
100 let me write this down bigger so the
square root is this big check looking
thing the square root of a hundred and
when you see it like this this means the
positive square root if you're familiar
with negative numbers you know that
there's also a negative square root but
when you just see this symbol that means
the positive square root so let's think
about what this is saying this is asking
us find the number the positive number
that when I multiply by when I multiply
that number by itself I get 100 so what
number when I multiply by itself do I
get a hundred let's see if I multiply 9
by itself that's only going to be 81
if I multiply 10 by itself that is a
hundred so this is equal to and let me
write it this way normally you could
skip the step but you could write this
as the square root of and instead of 100
100 is the same thing as 10 times 10 and
then you know the square root of
something times itself that's just going
to be that's something this is just
equal to 10 so the square root of 100 is
10 or another way you could write I
guess the same truth is that 10 squared
which is equal to 10 times 10 is equal
to 100